on this episode my dear friend and
business partner Matt Higgins stops by
also he's about to be a shark hey
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 297 of the askgaryvee
show and I'm super excited because on
the show no all right so this is
literally probably the person I'm most
closest to that I've ever done a show
with my business partner over the last
decade we'll get into that a minute but
Matt Higgins is here a couple things
that are exciting about this episode
number one he looks better than ever
which makes sense because he's on this
incredible publicity spree because he is
now a shark on one of the most famous
shows in business period are you wearing
shark socks I see that guest star of
shark tank this year very much
well-deserved I'm gonna let you tell I'm
gonna let him tell you his origin story
because that's what we do with every
guest here but it in turn wines very
much with my career as well and I think
a lot of you will enjoy and then and
really where I want to go because we're
both here I think knowing my audience I
want to do as many calls as possible
which is something we haven't been doing
as much so I'm gonna let Matt kind of
establish comic-book number one tell us
you know kind of origin story then I'll
throw out a couple questions and then
we'll get into the the phone call so
Facebook I know you're watching live
right now put in your phone call and
your question especially as Matt starts
telling a story I think it would make
sense Matt how are you I'm doing Gracie
but thanks PJ Oh take it away all right
who are you who am I go like drop the
whole bit I tend to like those all right
I grew up in Bayside Queens okay on
Springfield Boulevard mornin flushing
Hospital mm-hmm hustled in Queens my
whole early life first job McDonald's
actually first first job selling flowers
on the street mm-hmm second job
McDonald's I grew up real poor taking
care of money you know this but yelling
you like you don't I don't know and um I
grew up single mother it was amazing
and taking care of four miserable boys
yes and and what boy were you I was the
I was the youngest sometimes you know
[ __ ] rolls downhill so so it landed in
my lap but I grew up really poor and
everybody says that but government
cheese in the refrigerator and you know
the whole bit
yeah Church pantries on Sunday and my
mother was amazing and always trying to
get ahead in life but everything for me
was about how do I get out of this
situation as quickly as humanly possible
yes and as quickly did you figure that
out you think like what now when you
reconcile that like it's been
interesting to me how many things I've
realized about myself as I've talked
about myself done speeches things that
nature attention was the big one like
holy crap I didn't run lemonade stands
I watched cars to watch people holy crap
I wasted the wasted the first three
hours of baseball card show to watch
what people were doing with their
attention that is something I didn't
know until like four or five or six
years ago now that you're talking about
your career and things that nature when
do you think you at this point right
this minute when do you think you woke
up and said holy crap I gotta get out of
it I think what I was ten years old
I remember I just something happened
where it seemed like really desperate
and had an epiphany that if things don't
go in a different direction they're not
gonna end well
and I remember what you were born I was
1974 got it so many before 84 okay I
bunch of things happened in my mother's
life and you know she was well she was
very depressed and just sick and she
date other guys no no we grew up that's
interesting you ask that yeah we were
kind of a unit and and for some reason
around that time I Mariah had been in a
bus accident and I was standing at the
ocean looking at the way he's thinking
like okay this is this is not gonna end
well and and I kind of I think that was
the beginning of the me being a little
bit of a loner and deciding like I need
to figure out a way out and was a loner
do you this is a question we this is
what's fun about this I've never really
gone in some of these places with you
I'm getting uncomfortable I know you
should because I'm about to go there
lone rested like okay not that I don't
want to be like my brothers yeah when
you're number four and I'm listening and
I've never thought about it this way but
we're putting on a show here you want to
be on the show here you go do you mean
loner like and by the way it's
interesting because I have a version of
this
- which is like and I've had such good
things that I'm deal with it's just like
sometimes you just go inside your head
yeah actually now I've never thought
about what do I mean by that word but
now I do we used to go to the emergency
room all the time for healthcare cuz we
we had nothing and that became kind of
our doctor and it's the time when I
started realizing that these are
intractable problems you don't use that
word at ten but like there's no answer
to this and that you have to kind of
take matters into your own hands not
like I had the answers at ten but I
definitely had the problem at ten yes
and and then something happened back to
pattern recognition when I was a kid
my mother actually got a GED as an adult
and she was able to go to college she
did really well and around the time that
I was in eighth grade I said wait a
second if she was able to go to college
as an adult kind of by accident if I did
this on purpose then I can get out of
this situation even faster so then so
stay and listen I grew up the same time
as you did like school became a gateway
out yes school to Gateway out but also
unnecessary like it just didn't add up
like okay I have a desperate
circumstance or a very poor we need to
move quickly she's getting progressively
you know sicker right um and then
there's this side path which is if you
actually drop out at sixteen and do well
enough you can go to college so that was
probably the first most unconventional
decision I ever made that everybody said
you're crazy like you're you're throwing
it away
and when I say loner it's the when I
started to cultivate this voice in my
head like hey wait a minute I have a
plan and I don't need anybody else to
agree to it yeah because they're not
looking at the apartment and they don't
have context you always say it all the
time which I love nobody nobody had a
window I'm for some when you're a kid
you're trying to wear Jordache jeans or
guess I'm dating myself right you're
doing everything you can to conceal your
shame sure so and everybody was saying
you're insane to drop out of high school
is like no you don't know what you're
talking about now when I made the move
and I dropped that Accardo as a high
school at 16 and I was like okay you
know right now if people drop out of
high school like in 2018 2019 and
they've got a plan
there's a level of like oh that might be
an entrepreneur that's gonna go do
something when you and I were growing up
anybody that dropped out of high school
was a hundred percent certified loser oh
forget about it right yeah and it's
funny I remember even I think just went
back to like New York tops I know when I
use him forget it but you did row and I
when I
like sent you back it was the most queen
surreal no I have to hang out with the
most queens II like that a little bit
just that moment just put you back in
there so I remember all right now I'm
gonna take it real I remember sitting on
the steps first of all you have to
return all your text books when you drop
at a high school back then at least so
you have to go class the class and I
remember walking into my science
teachers class mr. Rosenthal if you're
out there it's stuck and I went to bring
back my textbook and he goes you know
Higgins like what a shame what a waste
yeah and he goes yeah I remember he told
me I'll see you at McDonald's yeah at
the time I did work at McDonald's so if
you see me at McDonald's cuz I own it
that was all talk yeah went out sound
the steps of crota as I smoke too but
cuz now I was gonna get picked up by
truant police at that point yeah and I
thought damn like that was a ballsy move
it and so what happened next I executed
okay I said I radio I went I started
taking a GED classes for like a week all
right this is not for me okay you're
allowed to take it on standby if you
show up I went to Springfield Gardens
High School
okay and Queens I went on standby took
my GED took the SATs a couple weeks
later and within three months I enrolled
in Queens college at 16 okay then just
to prove a point went back to my prom in
high school as president at the bay team
and I was like how do you like them
apples to date myself yeah so that's it
to me that's probably one of those
important things ever happened in my
life because everything you talk about
you don't have contacts so I'm not gonna
listen to you because your opinion
doesn't matter because you don't have
the full story I mean that is just right
I have a plan and if I have a plan and I
believe in the plan that's more
important than anything else that's
going on right and I have pattern
recognition skills that maybe set me
apart so trust in them right yet they
can get you where you want to go and
your point about how you get judged by
being a dropout I knew that I'm gonna
have to make sure that the that the rest
of the track record can overcome that
one decision so it's like it's like
being a six round pick right your judge
for being a six round pick until you go
to the Hall of Fame exactly said well
it's funny he said Law School was my
Hall of Fame cuz that's like a so I came
up with this art I'll go to law school
because I'll do his Babs on Law Review
is you know top of the class whatever I
went through four years of law school at
night and as soon as I graduated I never
even took the bar that's okay I clean
that up and then what happen well all in
between yeah my career was taken
right so because I dropped out early got
great jobs early like what I actually do
don't know so I while I was doing that I
was working as a reporter for the
Queen's Tribune okay and people would
send me their problems I created a
little column called the Trib action
desk okay and they would send me their
problems about things they were did and
they were mundane issues yes but I would
take the mundane and make it very
interesting yes you know some some guy
and Hamilton Beach Queens and the city
had built a bridge next to his house and
the bridge had started destroying the
foundation and he had an animal Moroccan
menagerie and I could ended up blowing
up in the air papers like things like I
would take these crazy stories I Drive
around my little Nissan Maxima with the
broken radiator like all night long and
who like took note of that a lot of
different reporters Daily News did a big
profile on me you know called me a real
action hero you know and it started
happening started happening and then
ultimately Mayor Giuliani gave him my
first kind of big job what were you
doing before Giuliani I was doing the
like a dot-com thing like Cosmo I was in
between yeah what was that Cosmo you
were worth the trillion I was where the
trillion I was amazing I was so rich ten
thousand I'll help me right here because
this is where all the kids like you know
I keep like I just can't wait for the
world to melt yeah as you know I don't
like when you say that I know you get
worried like yes but like um I still
have like pts yes I know but mattress II
yes nearly French well I think you just
want to get back there I'm like no no I
lose it I want to navigate the storm
yeah and what you like the big reveal
I'm done with the big reveal no I get it
but here's the good news in this
scenario you've got your own other
things but you'll be able to watch I'll
be that's right um you know right now a
lot of kids are either doing well I was
at a conference yesterday and I talked
where it's a lot of videographers a lot
of vloggers a lot of influences on the
guys you do understand the $39,000
you're making this year in brand deals
on Instagram photos goes away when the
economy gets tight because coca-cola
gets tight it's cruel of you and tell
you no no it's the single best thing I
was good right because everybody's
living in fantasy you lived in fantasy
land with your cosmos stock and already
thought about what was gonna happen and
it all went to dead zero that's what I
was about it I learned something at
Cosmo that was so
right so so I so I go to cus okay will
Cosmo one of the biggest Internet
companies at the time nice three hundred
million dollars in 1998 it would deliver
everything to you and under deliver
everything to you in under an hour
it's actually an amazing company right
last mile ten thousand employees ten
cities by the way here we are 20 years
later still no last mile another thing
people need to land interesting that the
business could have been profitable at
an average order of $24 2.5 orders per
hour and there was no smartphone making
those orders that's right anyways burn
into my head right oh it was interesting
the signs were everywhere towards the
end and I remember thinking we got
somebody joined the company as our CFO
at the time and he had what were you
doing I was director of coms cube
because I did the roadshow the whole bit
so this I won't say who the person was
but they quit this massive job why at a
moment when I'm saying the signs are
everywhere that we are about to go under
I was completely seduced by the objects
witty and Here I am the Giuliani offers
me a chance to become the youngest press
secretary in New York City history for
which I'd have to leave my trillion
dollars of options and I had to none of
it was vested well no none of it was
vested right was sort of you know locked
up but I had to make okay here's this
person who's got this big job making
this decision to join the company the
exact moment that I feel like we're only
weeks away from total imminent you know
decline and yet I have to decide to walk
away so I and I made the right choice I
made more money selling the gear on eBay
you know then I did you know company
with the options but the point of that
story is trust your instincts like don't
don't outsource your judgment to
somebody who has less what was the max
value of all those stocks on paper I'm
in a few million dollars that made this
but I never tried to get too close to
yeah but that was like you know I know I
want right I was rich and then one zero
hey I went to zero it could happen to so
many people soon yeah that's gonna be an
interesting what's interesting about the
collapse of o1 no7 was there wasn't a
maturity of social media what I'm
unbelievably worried about and why I
keep talking about it and I will
continue to talk about it basically
every day is we have a bunch of people
that are posturing of success on
Instagram and Facebook and Twitter every
single day right and they're all a 99%
are gonna lose because they're over
leveraged
which means that they're gonna have to
deal with the fact of that judgment at
scale like you weren't post
like we can't look at your Twitter from
2002 talking big game at being at Nobu
right because you had two million in the
bank as a twenty-something in stock but
that's what was happened do you think
that do you think the cycles the same
now I remember companies because funded
pet stock share I do are people getting
funded on my you believe people that are
claiming on Instagram right now that
they're building the next supreme
or the next Instagram and every picture
during the summer is in the Hamptons on
Aswan when they go work at Chase in two
years because they're out of business
that's gonna hurt yes I do I think that
is a problem okay what are we gonna do
in that collapse we're gonna make a lot
of money because we're preparing for
that and are building a machine Manor
media is built in a way like all the
margin I don't deliver is predicated on
capturing the growth when Poland Springs
goes from a hundred million to a twenty
nine million dollar budget and they have
to make that work so you know but but
it's not like I'm like hee hee hee being
secretive I'm just I'm telling people
what I'm doing my biggest advice always
to my audiences watch what I'm doing not
what I'm saying because then you'll
really know what the hell's going on
what's going on I'm eating crow running
this goddamn company because I know how
rueful it will be when inevitable that's
why I always say I always think the one
thing that you don't give enough insight
into is just how hard you work as an
operator how much you spend all your
time just like and how right you are on
trends business trends right now about
what an incredible insight not to blow
smoke but you are and from that first
time we met in a bagel store all right
that's what I saw I think so let's go
quickly because I want to get yeah I get
bored of the bio story Giuliani you're
with him during 9/11 that's an episode
in itself that I mean that that you
should be putting content about just to
it's just you should put it for your you
know like just four generations in a
future just interesting stuff like to be
at the hip of Mayor Giuliani during 9/11
is one of the unique life's in America
yeah I don't know like you it's it's
yours thus it's hard for you to see it I
don't know how big that team was or
wasn't but you're talking about 40 20 to
help me here jumping in 1927 what was
the core circle of team Giuliani on 9/11
that's probably yeah it's 25 people I
was doing think about
out of 300 plus Americans who you know
there's some young people who didn't
it's crazy now to think about how many
people were talking 17 years ago 17
years ago man it's crazy that 22 year
olds don't know yeah they don't like how
old are you
you know like it starts to take out here
how are you but in Houston I'm sorry man
I wasn't sure like you were in America
on 9/11 what what do you think about
when I say 9/11 do you remember anything
Brooke how are you 22
you know it what are you but how but
like for you
9/11 is like is it like Pearl Harbor or
is it yes like Vietnam is nothing like
it meant something you're five right so
that's what you remember
but like it's great anyway nonetheless
yeah for most you know like it's crazy
to think that you were so close to like
probably the signature moment of the
majority of people's lives in American
history and I was standing outside when
the first building collapsed yeah right
and we were setting up to do well the
one thing about Giuliani he handled a
crisis by letting everybody know that
you know it was under control and that
he was it was a curse so right before
the first tower collapse I was standing
outside setting up a press conference
so that he could do what he normally
would do we didn't say that we've got
this yep and then it just was so clear
that this is a war zone this is unlike
but in the beginning you remember he
wasn't clear it was the first report
plane it was it assessed yeah and so for
me that was it that began a two-year
chapter right because I was there from
that moment stayed with Giuliani as
press secretary managing the global
response to the attack which became its
own obligation right how do we Telegraph
what happened here how do we enlist the
support of the world yeah and then I
became the first employee of the
rebuilding so you I arrived with a cell
phone and a massive federal budget with
a group of people to start rebuilding I
spent two years of my life
moved down there I would sit on the roof
of my building on Chambers Street and
write speeches you know while everything
was still you know going on so it was
just basically that day really lasted
for two years that's why it's hard for
me to tell this to
because it's still kind of a blur like I
don't totally understand it I haven't
gone back and looked at all the footage
and understood the impact and then what
happens next so I did two years I
decided I was gonna see it through until
we had a design for the memorial and the
Freedom Tower and then I transitioned I
to the New York Jets that's right the
New York Jets were looking for somebody
to help them build a stadium yes No
oh yeah here here like that literally
here here this Hudson Yards project so
we wait we waged an epic you know calm
war battle right no expense
both sides probably almost a hundred
million dollars fighting Cablevision
yeah I went to war to stop it thank you
so that lasted probably two years and
ultimately how close did it get it got
really close we had a majority of the
City Council supporting it for everybody
was listening this is obviously very
emotional for me yeah the Jets wanted to
build way more for me than you I don't
give a [ __ ] how involved you with that
emotionally yes this that this part is
emotional for me fair enough but we are
living literally the office building
we're in right now is in the spot that
was battled over in the early 2000s
about where the New York Jets almost
built their stadium which would have
been in Manhattan and as somebody who's
a Jets fan in a town that is very giant
stout you can imagine having the actual
stadium in Manhattan was obviously very
attracted I'm a Jersey boy and I love
that it's out there but it was an
attractive proposition of the Jets and I
was gonna head home to the Olympics
that's exactly right
the Olympic bid so what's so hard to
explain the convoluted political process
but it was a war of television ads and
tens of thousands of a union I was crazy
it was crazy and I ran that fight and
then it died on the steps of the Capitol
when Shelly silver who's now going to
jail Shelly's been evicted and yeah well
see the bitterness last hold on yep
and we lost yep right so then the and
the reason why the Jets chose me they
needed somebody who had that background
and any politics and whatnot and what
did you come in as I come in as like VP
of strategy and then what
and every other job eventually ending up
as EVP of the business the business of
the team yes how long were you how long
were you with the Jets eight years ma'am
that's nice it's a real run when I was I
started the Jets when I was probably 28
and uh Hofstra was headquarters well
headquarters in Manhattan I was in
Manhattan we are out in Hofstra and then
when I ran that process yep right so I
ran the process to figure out how to
build a practice facility in New Jersey
yep and then relocated in New Jersey out
of anger
I met we met because what we met because
I was trying tell you is sweet you were
like I know we have this like pinup at
the at the team at the time who could
afford a suite but isn't buying one
right wine library yeah and you were
like you were you were you know you were
talking another it was a weight and that
bagel store was a target-rich
environment right so to cover such an
unbelievable story really quick cuz I
wanna get into other parts as career
it's about Matt I want to get but
because it's the Genesis story right so
I'm running Wine Library this is as me
and AJ are plotting vaynermedia but
nobody knows so I'm actively just
running Wine Library I get an email from
the Jets which always gets responded to
right away and the president wants to
meet you and I'm like hell yes and we
went to bagel Smith and on Springfield
Avenue in Springfield New Jersey yes
right so I'm going to sell garius wheat
which is not something that you love to
do as an executive it's a hard thing to
sort of sell I go to meet Gary Jeff
Fernandez that asked us to do it right I
go to meet Gary in a bagel store and
then the first 10 minutes I'm listening
to you with your frenetic energy and
your predictions and I didn't I didn't
follow you on on on Wine Library but I
always remember always think about the
second 10 minutes right cuz that's when
all this magic happened Gary started
telling all these stories about how the
world was gonna unfold and to give you
example I started making predictions
that I'm Matt in another couple of years
everything is gonna be about social
media and digital content but more
importantly content is going to be
democratized and everybody is going to
become their own content publisher and
because of that these corporations are
like big battleships they're not gonna
be able to manage that in-house
they're never gonna have enough
sophistication to figure out how to how
to go ahead and tap into that and
there's going to be a new type of agency
that'll be born that will figure out how
to manage that and I'm the guy to do it
interesting sounds legit and my brother
AJ and I are gonna with soon as he
graduates cuz he's 12 we're gonna watch
this big coming and I'm gonna be a
billionaire I'm gonna buy the Jets you
[ __ ] tell everybody so you know it's
going back to pattern recognition smoke
in the butt
on high school yeah I over those years I
started trusting myself that when I see
a pattern playing out and I see somebody
speaking the truth who's got the courage
to get it right and it resonates with me
I don't care if anybody else in the
world knows if they're right or not so
within those first those in second ten
minutes I was like oh Gary is sitting in
the stream of information and data he's
opening himself up to the world and is
starting to see the patterns and he's
right and I know if you remember - you
started predicting you know I think all
the things that you I wish I was
recording that meeting ya know there was
a really good on me right now
it really would yeah so with that and
that's why I tell everybody you know I
miss cliche but you know where the puck
is going so for at that meeting we did a
deal right yeah a couple things take a
jets player who doesn't deserve to be
famous and they come Twitter famous
that's right I was mission number one
and if you succeed we'll give you four
jets tickets to become the first client
I know others claiming yeah but I'm
gonna claim I am the first yep and to
make me the guy in sports who gets it so
I can get a huge job total self dealing
check check check and check and none of
those early articles do I credit carry
which I'm sorry one of them so you give
me [ __ ] about a journal or yes so Matt
Higgins master my social media rise of
the New York Jets and I'm reading if
it's somewhere I'm somewhere in here
nope not in there by the way even in
Fast Company I pulled a so but remember
we had dinner and in China would shadow
Harry Caray roads one of my favorite
players of all time and you made him you
massive Kerry Rhodes at one point was
literally the second or first most
followed football player as a safety for
the New York Jets on Twitter the Jets
were the number one team followed on
Twitter in 2009 and 10 period and so
yeah we did a lot of great work was a
lot of fun I remember my first meeting I
was like we just drafted Sanchez and I
was like I don't need like because
sports marketing is like marking around
the stars and I was like I want to make
the punter famous I want to make the
people that cover coverage on special
teams and I still believe that to this
day I still believe to this second the
biggest form of
in sports marketing is they give too
much power to the individual athlete and
the athlete should be doing that
everybody should be doing what they
should be doing but any was a great run
of America but you know member how hard
it was until early days like you would
get a cease and desist letter for
marketing on MySpace I remember I think
2009 I got a cease and desist letter
from the NFL like you're not allowed to
mark it on myspace right so it wasn't
easy to go ahead and the players were so
scrapping with am I allowed to use
Twitter for Simon actually not even
grapple he wasn't even allowed right so
we were we were we were breaking down
walls back in a way where ourselves
credit and then your career transitioned
again and by the way I don't think I've
ever told you the story I came to a Jets
practice during pre-season and you said
hey there's something brewing in my
career and I remember I'm thinking you
remember that lovely uh-huh and I
remember thinking no no Matt I like you
at the gym right right you're like the
Jets did ya don't leave but you were
right ya know I I like you I always had
the desire to be an entrepreneur and I
had all these ideas that were
percolating in my head and I think you
you reach a tipping point right at two
o'clock in the morning like I can I can
run this we were talking about creating
a fun together Gary's got all this great
insight if only we could monetize it
jesse Darris our partner and my PR firm
I knew that he needed to be running his
own firm and just all these ideas and it
just it reached a tipping point how long
did Ross Steve Ross who now we're gonna
transition to the Dolphins who brought
you on board how long was he courting
you as an executive was that quick court
I don't know this story yeah I think I
think I had made a I was going through a
lot of personal transitions in my life
and I had to made the decision like okay
if I don't transition out of this job
I'm never gonna leave it like sometimes
it's tough when you have a job that
everybody in the world you know once or
a lot of people want it's very hard to
listen to your inner voices say that's
great that this is the job you want but
I've run my course yeah eight years and
if you know the office on the 50-yard
line and the private plane they're very
hard to let that go so I made a decision
I was gonna I was gonna transition and
when that got out there that's when I
started to have conversations with Steve
and Steve is a maverick I mean he's he's
sitting in that in that room of NFL
owners and he's just of a different
breed and he had all these ideas that he
wanted to pursue around the team that
resonate
with me and I had all these ideas that I
wanted to put to work and and he
supported it right I mean in ways that
are looking back are kind of
breathtaking right and including
becoming partners with you and building
this huge international soccer
tournament that we have and drone racing
and you know on and on but that was six
years ago that we created our se so in
to speed it up and then we're getting
into QA in the last six years that you
created RSC what are the what are the
highlights so you start this company
yeah what Steve I started a company with
Steve you're also you also become an
executive on the Dolphins side right and
right and and you're an employee on that
side and exactly yeah so the the the
oversee the dolphins on the business
side put in place a great team but let
it run itself and we have an amazing CEO
named Tom Garfinkel so that took care of
itself right but let's build an
ecosystem around the team that could
either help drive value or extract value
from right so some of the early deals
you were on that first PowerPoint he's
amazing looking at my first pitch deck
yes there are four ideas and you were on
that yes and look at where we are
Jesse darris was on that list creating
an international soccer business was on
that list cuz we're in Miami fast
forward we have the largest soccer
tournament in the world and I remember
city would Steve is his desk about three
months in going through the pitch and
he's like that's a lot of stuff you sure
you're gonna do it I was like oh yeah
yeah you'll see we do it so since then
what are the highlights I think seeing
in somebody something that maybe even
they don't see in themselves yet and
extracting it and weaponizing I love it
do you do you believe that shark tank
I'm jumping here a little bit put you on
because you've been so good at picking
entrepreneurs and investing in them and
and when I look at me and I feel like I
am one but then I think the chapter that
you've had recently that has been more
in the food space and I like I think
Jesse's a real maverick of a young
entrepreneur too but the when I look at
what you did with David Chang or some of
what you're doing in food seems to be
more of a pattern of what you did with
me and it and then you did it within a
genre of food yeah talk to me about so I
think what should give people context
yeah the company's invested in whom what
company so we're four spaces sports and
entertainment
drone racing international soccer huge
tournament food and lifestyle so we own
we incubate a resi together yeah David
Chang is my partner milk bar and pizza
blue stone Lane a bunch of different
sort of large fast casual companies and
finally I see a blue star Stone extent
Nick yep MPN pizza yeah who's real
amazing raising profit I mean these are
you know the blue stone guys but they're
dynamic in all different ways yeah they
are I think so
you're asked why would Shark Tank want
me on yeah I mean I think it's because
because I know a lot of entrepreneurs
are watching and when you're on this
season I think it's super you know it
makes me
I'm so happy you're on because I think
there's I think what they've done with
guests whether it's been Ashton or Sokka
or like they've gone for just Alex
Rodriguez there's been a lot of
front-facing people yeah that's right
Europe you know you're
disproportionately the least famous
guest shark which I love I would say
that I favorite comment I think I sent
this to you when it was announced
somebody commented on ABC's page saying
but he only has four hundred followers
yeah and I wrote back I said four
hundred one question mark as good as
when I was on planet e apps and the
article was and in a new show apples
first original show the guests saw that
the the judges are Gwyneth Paltrow will
I am Jessica Alba and others by the way
I'm sure you have a lot into promos
others do I decide not to be offended
because I know I like you I'm starting
to love the big reveal so why did they
put me on I think my my day job and my
hobby is helping people transcend
because I was that kid that had all this
potential and that had to break through
in order to transcend to what I was
meant to be so for me there's something
magical about unlocking that butterfly
that's in anybody when you play I
apologize because I'm looking at the
time and I want to get some calls and so
I apologize let me give an insight to
the people that always get mad at me for
interrupting
these our time slotted unlike other
people whose entire life is being a
podcaster and they have unlimited time
and they do post-production we slot them
in because we have busy peeps and we
have to stay with every chance to each
other
I'm so that's true Matt when you've been
wrong about entrepreneurship because
you've been betting on entrepreneurs
over the last half decade plus pretty
aggressively and it is now becoming your
brand and I'm inevitably especially with
the association with me especially with
Shark Tank you are in for a decade of
people reaching out and saying I'm the
next David Chang like that's gonna be
your life at least until you change it
right it is very clear for me from the
outside yeah because I think the thing
that people we I like that life yeah I
mean it's a very interesting thing like
I think one thing even if I don't know
if you guys are picking up on this
nuance and this is true with my dad and
my brother let alone a majority investor
into my company the key plug to the
relationship Matt will tell you that it
is shocking how much and how little we
actually talk business right like
everyone's so busy and just I'm the kind
of entrepreneur that's not so detailed
let's have a meeting every month like
review what's happening but what so I'm
actually it's been fun for me to watch
you go through this process the last
hundred days in anticipation of Shark
Tank I'm like wow you know it is very
clear what Matt's life is gonna look
like for the next half decade which is
people are just gonna pitch him left and
right I'm like I'm the next entrepreneur
that you should bet on so to that point
I when you've been wrong in the last six
years even if it's not a bet you made
where you wanted to make the bet and you
didn't because the price was too high or
they didn't take your money and then you
got to watch her or him win or lose when
you've been wrong why do you think
you've been wrong its number one reason
there are minor reasons number one is
when I thought that the power of the
idea would eclipse whatever flaws are in
the founder it's when I decided to
overlook the fact that the jockey
doesn't have what it takes and say well
the idea is so good horses so specialist
take I'm sure they're others every
mistake has always been has been about
the idea the idea will eclipse the
founder and that's never true so is
about two people that's really
interesting you say that because now
that I was thinking that might is what
you said because it's been I've been
very intrigued by this chapter in the
food space because I really personally
from afar like the bets yeah and I do
think they're different than the kind of
things you were looking at because we
looked at a lot of stuff together when
we had vayner/rse our fire
together I do think there's a maturity
in the way that you're picking jockeys
yeah
well I'm picking special first right I'm
picking ideas that are potentially
scalable right I don't want to pick
something that could just be a couple of
units as you and I learned the hard way
small ideas and big ideas take the same
exact amount of where it's an
interesting secret secret of life right
you would assume that there'd be a
massive increase in work to make a big
idea the same exact game which is
exciting because that means you can keep
leveling up and do big stuff but um I'm
backing special backing scalable and
backing people who have the confidence
and the humility to make it work right
because if you don't have humility
you'll never pivot and if you don't have
confidence you'll never become for all
to have humility right I think that's
come on take some call yeah that's right
I think that contradiction of confidence
and humility is something I talk a lot
about I believe in it can I give a shout
out this is my wife Sarah's over that's
all right she is she the confidence sort
of human she's the whole package that's
why what are you I'm only I'm inadequate
she barely City Michael Michael Michael
this is Gary Vaynerchuk you're on the
askgaryvee show with Matt Higgins how
are you out Dan bean I have to leave
that I actually got the call in and hey
Matt how's it going I'm doing great I'm
glad to hear you're outstanding so my
question go ahead we're here I've known
each other first three four years now on
brother you chopped off for a second are
you no good Michael two things one your
voice scared the [ __ ] out of everybody
watching when you were laughing it was a
very evil laugh we're all very scared
but number two you cut off when you ask
your question so ask it again please so
I said I was a big fan of both you Gary
and I've known Matt for about three four
years now so my question is for Matt
when you acquire these companies or
invest in these companies what are you
looking at are you looking for growth
are you looking for future sale what is
your overall as Gary would say your
macro approach well I'm a little
different than a firm or some PE shop
because I'm I'm partnered with Steve
Ross so the philosophy is we don't worry
about the exits the exits will be a
byproduct of success we don't
force our founders to do that so we're
looking for something that can be an
inherently big business maybe not in the
first you know version 1.0 of me but
certainly version 3.0 now a big business
and that there is an inevitable path to
exit but we're not gonna focus on it
right so a business that could be sold
that could exit but it's all about
growth
it's not about distributing cash flow
it's not about you know financial
engineering and you know Excel sheets as
gary says it's just about growth
excellent and the final question I have
and I know not a lot a lot of questions
the final question is how is the person
that runs probably and owns probably one
of the most storied franchises of the
dolphin's partner with the most craziest
yes fan out there well I've been looking
to sell our stake in the firm for a long
time so the answer is I'm raising my
profile to find a buyer what we just
don't talk about it I mean it's i don't
i don't razz him about it because he's
so emotional I do not give him [ __ ]
because it's an area I don't want to go
to and I don't say too much either
because one time when I was getting on
Ross real heavy in a meeting he looked
at me and he said you're a fan of the
team I own the team and that hurt yeah
that was pretty enough a pretty much
decided I would never really go anywhere
he did to me what I liked to do to
others so yes but you know to give some
insight so when we when we when we play
the Jets
right Gary won't even come over and say
hello right like usual on it you won't
even it's like it's like what do you
work there because yeah we're you're
pretty I mean you wanted to shake our
hands in the sidelines yes Steve always
goes your tribal he always yells at me
your tribal I mean look one of the worst
if not the single worst business
decision in my life
financially I offered you yeah Steve and
Matt within our transaction of them
investing in Boehner there was a there
was equity and the Dolphins offered and
we went a different route we had the
soccer idea that we did the fund but but
the multiple of the growth like I mean I
lost tens of billions of dollars in not
by being a Jets fan big mistake they
would say I'm pretty well I hope to see
you on the Jets are you coming down to
the Jets Dolphins game yeah yeah
I'm not I'm in LA doing something so I'm
on a red-eye like meeting right now with
my I actually had that conversation
today I would say very likely yes one
with you Matt right yes thanks for
calling brother thanks for calling yeah
um yeah I mean I think look I think that
what's super interesting about the
jockey horse conversation is that like
it is very clear to me like what I mean
I've not been doing much investing we
did our fund yeah we you know I've been
kind of very head down and building the
banner machine I think things are
overvalued in general for me for
early-stage
I think interesting but the jockeys were
and I think the next phase that you and
I will go through together is control
like if I'm back in Gary Vee directly
it's much more interesting some time
sheet to some anonymous company a
hundred percent like like I'm only into
control now that's the whole macro thing
of a future control like I don't want to
guess are we teasing out our next move
I've been very public about verifier
Nathan its Gary Vaynerchuk you're on the
askgaryvee show with Matt Higgins I knew
wow what a freaking honor how are you
guys good Nathan from I just mainly
would call it because almost of times
from two winners and what had happened
is in the last year so we kind of blown
up on Facebook live so much last part
I've kind of gotten a little overwhelmed
we passed a five million dollar orchid
I'm sorry to have to handle employees
and things like that trying to make like
let's step into that top million dollar
range 2019 it up just a little bit over
where of trying to you and Nathan you're
out Nathan I just want to start thinking
while you're talking did you say a
sports bar baseball card baseball cards
yes okay this is very exciting to me
Matt get out of here I'm doing five
million in revenue and baseball cards
so Nathan real quick where are you
located I'm in Murfreesboro Tennessee
right so we've interacted right that's
correct
cool so this is you're the guy of DM
with a bunch right like you've grown a
lot in both at your retail store in the
last couple years right correct
on the back of social media marketing
advice correct yeah makes me super happy
um okay
and so now you're saying [ __ ] this is
continuing to work and I can feel it
going to the next level and with that
comes new dynamics which is I'm not just
standing behind the counter of my store
and posting on social to the scale I'm
at I've got to bring in new employees so
now I'm getting to more of an HR human
game not just being the marketer and
seller of 8687 clear basketball cards
that's exactly right yeah and so do you
hate it because I think one of the
things that a lot of people who are
watching right now have to understand
it's super okay to be in a transition
where you love your craft it was a small
business you're good at your craft
whether that's by the way being a lawyer
or doing a landscaping business or
selling baseball cards and that when it
grows it now becomes about people
management and for a lot of people that
are artists or good at their craft
there's a guy tell you AJ it's the
biggest issue and the growth of Boehner
was the unbelievable non enjoyment
managing people yeah are you saying that
you don't like it the early tastes of it
or you're scared to [ __ ] it up or what
oh no we I love what I do I haven't set
my alarm for last year no no I mean I
mean are you do not like the idea of
managing people that's right that
disgusted I hate it it's just that it's
just like anything else I've just
started out it I thought I wouldn't say
I'm very good at it right now I learned
that that goes when you say you're not
good what mistakes do you think you've
made say it out loud because putting it
out there will is a very important thing
it will help you what do you want
mistakes do you think you've made when I
gave trust to an employee when I saw a
brother hold on it's a it's a little
muffled that's why I thought you had a
sports bar not a baseball concert one
more time what was it
early on I I had an employee that I'd
given quite a bit of trust to trust and
when I saw that that trust was being
violated I didn't necessarily find that
immediately yes yeah you know
Garet we could we could visit right
about this all the time I mean yeah we
there's a nice cliche that nobody
actually follows which is higher slow
and fire fast so the mistake that you're
making is a mistake that Larry and I
made I'm making extremely fast and fire
slow exactly and and by the way a ghen
eyes it and as you should write these
are human nature let me say something
when people make fun of me or critique
me or there is one thing that I think as
a small business you'll appreciate this
brother let me give you a humongous
piece of advice for everybody
you have to sleep at night I am thrilled
to give up money every day of my life to
feel better when I go to sleep now that
makes me not as good of an entrepreneur
as I could be because when you're on the
field you're on the field like it is
what it is
but don't over judge yourself either you
know and and you're going through an
evolution I mean to me that there's
nothing wrong with you trying to find
your patterns on how to fire somebody
quickly and dirty dirty little secret
Nathan every single entrepreneur and
leader goes through the transition that
you're talking about and the biggest
lament is that they didn't act sooner
when they already knew because it takes
time to get used to that so I would I
would say but nobody talks about their
buddy talks a big game like IIIi don't
like staff issues right away no but
nobody does so if that's your biggest
issue you're you're you're doing great
what else have you [ __ ] up what are
you what are you most worried about
going into next year as you continue to
grow because I think you know I'm about
to make sports cards very culturally
popular in 2019 and all of you are gonna
benefit from it so you're gonna probably
do more revenue next year oh I know man
I really appreciate the help - I really
do training that I fear is we built this
big world what I consider a juggernaut
our industry and for whatever reason I
have this fear that one day I'm gonna
log on and there's not 500 people
watching you know it just goes away
whether that or or whatever he's
conscious
Matt let me let me help everybody's
watching what he's done is there's a big
thing called pack breaking which is
people basically people buy slots in
boxes of cards where you get the third
pack that he opens live on Facebook or
whatever live platform and you know you
can call it a form of gambling a form of
contests but like literally for example
there's a famous one he didn't do and
he's doing a great job I've seen some of
his but 8687 flee over at the Jordan
rookie yeah he will pay $2,000 a pac-10
and then if you get a Jordan or in his
world like what's the most expensive
pack break you've done brother
I mean we we open $1500 flawless
briefcases we open four or five last
night so a 1500 spent on stuff like that
yes so like and and in that box how many
packs order well there's only can
individual card right so you sort you
shall you sold the slots of the cart so
it even goes down to the pit so you sold
so it was a 1500 box and how much I just
want to teach everybody about this whole
business and you you sold you sold the
individual cards in the pack like the
first card Matt Higgins bought I bought
the third card from the pack how much
was the slot how much did you sell the
slots for if it's just 100 retail about
a box to say use or 1500 if it's not in
a group right
we might charge 64 - 5 makes 250 bucks
for other sports i watch pack breaks
that I'm not even in just waiting for
the big card to be like or the big card
to come out of the pack so Nathan let me
ask you a question if people stopped
caring to watch you do that why will
they stop caring when you when it keeps
you up at night Nathan let me give you a
good you said one example let me give
you a headline if a war breaks out
you're not gonna give a [ __ ] about your
pack break business like people like
Gary I'm worried a war breaks I'm like
if a war breaks out in our country
you're gonna be running to the bunkers
and I don't think like you know like the
last thing to be thinking about like
[ __ ] man there's a war going on New York
just blew up
I don't think 500 people are gonna tune
in to my factory
tonight good news like going back to
9/11 everything stopped yep
like if a war breaks out that's gonna be
the last [ __ ] keep going I see these
other things other than war that you're
worried about all right so wait so then
so then so then what I hear is you have
the typical paranoia of a founder and a
business owner who's worried it's all
let me - I still grapple with whether or
not I made it or not I mean Matt right
like real quick to interrupt I'll give
you an exact perfect sample on the
flight from LA this morning I had I
texted a client of ours we have a
division we have a thing at vaynermedia
called Vayner mentors for small
businesses it's kinda like being in
McKinsey pay one hundred two hundred
three hundred thousand dollars for a
project where we give you business
advice and marketing buddies to take
your business to the next level an
incredible young woman out of Florida
with a furniture store you used us it's
been rolling everything's going great
and then this hurricane just hit her
right
so like it's real to lay there can we
get joke about war it could be a
hurricane yeah you know Tennessee I mean
like I have a whole thesis of
earthquakes in Tennessee like you might
get hit by an earthquake Nathan and then
Nathan the fact that you're worried
about this now doing five million here
and a brilliant idea is why you're gonna
be at ten million dollars a year so
don't lament the fact that you have this
here no I'll tell you I'll tell you what
I'm worried about with your business is
that what you're winning on is you're a
first mover in it just like I was in
social media
like if cards continue to get as popular
as I think they're going to there's
gonna be a lot of other people breaking
packs and you're gonna have more
competition so you need to find another
way the way you found this to sell
sports cards the hardest thing for
people to do is put themselves out of
business I think the thing that I've
always done well which is why I don't
always kick the most profit but I always
build very big businesses and I'll win
in the end is whatever is working for me
I start creating other things that could
work for me because I don't want to be
reliant on one move pack breaking is
your move right now you need to triple
down on that to go to ten at the same
token you need to start creating
let's do it for storage unit so I can
watch it on TV live like I buy but like
Nathan you need to like start coming up
with something else like regional shows
or like a podcast or or like an event
once a month in your store physically
that people will want to travel to from
around the country because who the [ __ ]
knows there's a way to get a ten
thousand dollar card if I win X like
you're gonna need to add other sizzles
what you're about to do is fall in love
with the one sizzle that got you there
which then makes you vulnerable long
term do you understand yes yes wait
we're gonna do all that Gary we do trade
nights on you know what's a month we do
like I'm always listening like you say
Todd can't content content so I'll do
good I do kids videos we do kids
collectors club every month we do what's
it worth when they were what what are
you doing in there what you know the
other thing you can do is maybe take
some of the money you're making now
which is different than the kind of
money you made before and maybe you can
find the comic book version of you and
get into or the toy version of you and
maybe own 50% of a comic book store and
teach her or him your model and watch
her comic you know buy into her comic
book store that's only doing 800,000 in
revenue this year be the infrastructure
for her to do four million on the same
concept you came up with you see where
I'm going yes yes that burst okay before
you go I don't think he said what his
business was did he maybe the fine of
you a little plug grand-slam
collectibles in Murfreesboro Tennessee
all right I'm gonna check it out ransom
cloud really appreciates both y'all
y'all are both in this price for the
rest of us I'll keep it flat all right
are you gonna be watching shark Matt
what episode do we have on Sunday
October 21st at Sunday Easter October
21st
9 p.m. Sunday October 21st 9p M I expect
the vaynernation Devon it's actually
gonna be it's gonna be one of the best
episodes they've ever had is a very
heart-wrenching story so tune in it'll
be a special night is it when the guest
shark was terrible and they had to kick
him off that part of it but they edited
that out thank you take care Matt
October 21st
9 p.m. I want everybody right now to go
into their Google calendars set alerts I
want viewing parties I want them to see
such a weird spike in Nielsen ratings
that they can
only give credit to Matt Higgins so that
he becomes a permanent or whatever the
hell he wants exactly an Instagram -
right so that you're very hot guy yeah
it's been fun to watch you get serious
about your know I like Instagram because
that ami because you have to earn it
it can't be hacked it doesn't go viral
you have to work I like that I have to
engage people you have to talk it's very
organic and match I love that right like
you just you have to put in the effort
well all of them are like that real and
I feel like Twitter things can go viral
I don't know Instagram to me at least
being you know viral you just haven't
put out by return whatever so maybe
you're not teaching me do I not own a
big piece of what you do the biggest
issue there are thousand people here and
nobody helps me yes but listen my
Michael Jordan had two children that
wanted to play basketball too it's
sometimes it comes as wrong it's just
you know why I lost away but I don't
lose the way cuz of the show know you
told me you said if you don't lose
weight by January 1st I'm gonna
mursaleen make fun of it right you did
better that you said you were so fat I
did I don't know tell us 50 pounds it
looks great depends what happens you
don't eat carbs for a year and you know
psious thank you um what do you want -
what do you want to leave everybody here
with wrapping up now
what what what should the you know we
have a entrepreneurial kind of crowd
watching right now like what what should
what's a great tidbit or something
unique or or you know because so many of
them watch me like what's something that
people don't we referenced earlier I'm
smart I see the puck but I think people
know that like what an insight to me or
Chang or or somebody else like what what
could be a tidbit of like what people
aren't thinking about from your
perspective well what about you you are
what you what you see which I love about
you
everything that you put out is the same
thing that I get when we have our cup of
coffee so it's a it's a it's a credit to
you that um empathy is so important like
everybody I back who's been successful
has deep soulful empathy so along your
way Nathan was struggling with the fact
that he's not maybe firing as fast as
grappling with it that's probably a
byproduct of his empathy to hear in his
voice
keep your empathy you you can get to the
top while preserving it and for me what
I love money and fame expose people or
change them I always say this to him to
my wife I want my money and fat and
power and autonomy so I could be more of
who I am rather than less I think all it
does is reveal right I want to I want to
stay in the place that sixteen-year-old
kid
who felt powerless and I want to use
money and power and everything else to
inspire and eventually redistribute make
a difference and so that's who I was
before shark tank that's who I'll be
I'll be more of that after Matt question
you have a change you haven't change for
the bagel store like you know you don't
roll around think I'm Gary Vee like
you're I mean you can't walk two feet
with you people stop it which is very
irritating by the way but uh but you
seem to be okay with it I would never
want it I think I think I'll be honest
with you I think if anything I've become
I've only I've gone the other way like
I'm like just desperately like to me it
would be I would die if somebody thought
that I don't we talked about we talked
Gary and I talked about this topic all
the time cuz I don't know if this could
be totally cultivated you were born with
the ability to truly love and listen to
yourself and block out the hate which I
admire that we have these deep soulful
conversations I take in much more of the
criticism are you I say play more
defense it's just sort of how I'm wired
but what you have is magical I could to
encourage that in people to say just
trust that inner voice and self love
like that is the key I don't know where
it came from with you I guess it's in my
resume is a beast a beast and also look
and in you know it's you know maybe we
should I was listening to your story
carefully like it was really great for
me to be an immigrant a terrible student
not good at sports
my entire foundation of my youth was
adversity and people telling me I wasn't
thus like I didn't grow up in an
environment looking for anybody's
reinforcement like all I needed was
myself you know my mom I needed my mom
to a degree and then I was old enough
that that became me and so at some level
I just here's my big thing and you
you're this thing for me like thinking
about our conversations I'm just not
interested in the people that boo in the
second quarter like for me this is my
jumping on judgment or the hate along
the way if those people are right when
it goes to triple zero of the game then
I have to concede that truth if they
were right that I was full of [ __ ] not
as smart as I think like whatever it may
be and it ends I've had my career and I
was not successful I over leveraged I
went to zero I had to work for somebody
one day I would just like you should you
know I don't like shaking people's hands
after
you lose a game of basketball but I do
it because I lost and that's the facts
given that compass' of you do that is
super humid but I want to know what I
company but I don't think it has to be
and that's why I'm trying to bring more
wit like it's actually practical it's
the same reason that I don't get excited
the general beating the Browns
14-nothing at halftime the other day we
lost like just cuz I'm winning like I'll
be back to what he was worried about
just cuz I'm conceivably winning right
this minute everything could start going
downhill tomorrow and if it does then I
lost and it goes in a lot of ways it not
only goes professionally and this is
where I don't think people are being
thoughtful
I don't just score on the money part a
lot of people that boo us along the way
are just talking about money right mmm
Matt Lauer's Brian looks different today
than it did a year and a half ago he was
making 20-plus million 30 million
dollars right so to me back to the
empathy thing I'm going to I'm kinda
know you know this way better than most
very few people know it as well as you
do I will always leaving economics on
the table because I don't believe being
the greatest entrepreneur of this
generation is just the person that made
the most money like the reason I think I
can beat sucks and Elon and Sara Blakely
and others is because for me and I get
the judge cuz that's my life the
greatest entrepreneur dish generation is
not only somebody and I do think you
have to succeed I do think I have to
make lots of money cuz that's the game
of an entrepreneur but the one who
brings the most value to the
entrepreneurial space yeah that's
interesting I mean you put something out
the other you post that guy you worded
it but he said focus on what you do well
because other people focus enough on
what you're not doing well that's right
well is it interesting but a lot of
people take the opposite approach I got
to mitigate my downside I got to work on
what I'm not good because they beginner
all in our way today why cuz they don't
realize whoever they're scared is in
control of them is not as in control as
they think the board of directors the
CEO the 51% equity partner yes in the
micro of that moment definitely not in
the macro of life alright question of
the day every guest gets to ask the
question of the day so what question
half for the vaynernation is an amazing
opportunity for you to get some insights
to explain it so a little more well I'm
thrilled to now know that you don't
watch a show it okay when I have a guest
when I have a guest he or she gets to
ask a question and then thousands of
comments come on Facebook and YouTube
and some guests at silly things like
what's your favorite color
others are very strategic cuz they're
trying to actually literally get an
insight at that moment of like a trend
or a thing or then some people just
trying to scratch their itch the more
opinions on something that are debating
within themselves right now okay so
what's your question
alright what's what's a product that I
don't know about that you think I should
know about that is gonna be massive
that's not on the radar right now so I
can invite and be and help me carry rich
Thanks you keep asking questions we'll
keep answering them
[Music]